kim kardashian says she's not okay after
revealing her and kanye west's son saint
broke his arm having kids is just
there's no way to describe it but it's a
lot on thursday kim shared the news on
her insta story explaining that her
five-year-old son broke his arm in
several places
that's a snap of saint in a wheelchair
with his arm wrapped up alongside the
caption who do you think cried more
today my baby broke his arm in a few
places today i'm not okay
that i don't know she later shared this
pic of saints black cast writing poor
baby
so it's unclear how saint sustained his
injuries but we're sending him a huge
hug because he's really been through it
this year during a may episode of
keeping up with the kardashians kim
revealed that saint tested positive for
covid19 after she and her children had
been exposed to the virus
my little sainty just tested positive
for cobed so someone at school tested
positive and my son was around them as
for kim according to a source she's been
spending extra time with her kids these
days since filing for divorce from the
grammy winner back in february after
nearly seven years of marriage
you just gotta roll with it in fact kim
recently brought the whole family to
several of kanye's donda listening
parties first in atlanta in july the kkw
beauty founder and their four kiddos
north saint chicago and salm sat in the
audience to support and cheer on their
dad kim even matched kanye's look in a
red jumpsuit with matching boots
why not she later attended kanye's other
listening events dressing the kids in
outfits to match their dad and she even
slipped into a wedding dress to recreate
her i do's to her estranged husband
he's done miracles
he's done miracles on me
not exactly your everyday
run-of-the-mill exes right him and i
have been best friends for a really long
time
well a source previously told et that
kim and kanye are quote on great terms
quote although they are going through a
divorce they still spend time together
alone or with their kids adding that
they quote make it a priority to meet up
[Music]